hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round six of the uh 2021
norway chess it's uh our current leader
uh richard rapport versus ariane tari
and it's uh quite an exciting game
features another really awesome uh
bishop of the same color end game much
like we had in the game uh carlson
versus ferruja so let's dive straight
into it it's uh well very very enjoyable
uh so rapport with the white pieces
opens with d4 uh we have d5 by 30 c4
going for the queen's gambit and now e6
uh declining the gambit with knight to
c3 and now c5 going for the taj defense
c captures on d5 c captures and now uh
oh sorry not e captures on d5 we have c
captures on d4 and now well white could
just pick up the pawn this way uh first
queen to a4 check and this is the more
popular move uh saying that okay now you
have to block this and now after bishop
to d7 i'm going to capture now and now
you can develop the knight to d7 but
also you can develop it to c6 if you
first have to waste the tempo
capturing on d5 so this is exactly what
tari does and now knight to f3 uh
waiting to see if knight the c6 is
coming right away but if you play this
then queen
can just capture on d5 so knight to f6
first kind of adding another defender
here and now bishop to g5 pinning this
knight on g5 and now knight to c6
attacking uh rappers queen so queen back
to d3 and now there is a game uh where
bishop e6 was played just adding another
defender to the d5 pawn but here tariq
plays uh uh rook the c8 uh and it is now
uh already as of move9 that we have a
completely new game and the white has a
decision to make can you capture on d5
or not and it's uh well it's uh it's a
fun game uh regardless of uh the pawn
being captured or not but uh in the game
it was not captured rapper played pawn
to e3 but i will show what happens if
the pawn is captured so if white
captures the pawn then black has this
very nasty queen to a5 check and then
after we move back the knight knight to
c3 it seems like we just won a pawn and
you know it's perfectly fine but now
comes knight to b4 attacking white's
queen here so queen to d2 and now we
have this rook captures on c3 that's the
idea behind giving up the d5 pawn b
counters on c3 now attacking the knight
but now knight the e4 attacking the
queen the bishop the queen also attacks
the bishop on g5 after queen to f4 we're
just gonna capture on g5 and after queen
captures offering a queen trade now we
play this uh well knight to c to check
can be played but knight to d3 seems to
be even more deadlier
as now we're threatening queen captures
followed by queen captures on a1 so king
to d2 you have to defend the c3 pawn and
then we have something like knight to c5
going after this uh very nice fork that
threatens to win the white queen
but also it's just a very nice position
for black so instead after this check we
might just capture the knight here and
then we would see some like queen
captures and c3 check king e2 we're
gonna capture the rook on a1 and here
white probably forces a queen trade with
queen e5 check captures captures and you
get this position where the material is
completely equal black will of course
avoid giving up the bishop fair play
some like bishop to e6 and now you get
this black has a bishop pair and two
pawn islands with pawns being on both
sides of the board so the bishop player
is definitely uh you know having
advantage here whereas white has a
bishop at night and three uh pawn island
so black will will be better for the
rest of the game here and this is what
todd is saying uh when he's playing rook
to c8 you can't really capture on d5 so
rapport agrees he plays e3
and now h6 asking what do you do with
the bishop here so bishop to h4 and now
bishop to be for putting pressure on the
knight here so rook to c1 and now uh
tariq castles we have bishop to e2 also
preparing castles uh in the now g5 so
here
black says i want to expand here on the
king side but this also means that i
will have to worry about moves like h4
at some point and
my king side is is kind of
about to open up so here you could
continue with something like bishop to
e6 but we have the immediate bishop
captures on c3 uh b captures on c3 and
now bishop to e6 and now tari says all
right uh my position is now uh perfectly
fine uh you didn't really achieve
anything with the white pieces but i did
have to
uh
expand my pawns uh here uh in front of
my king a little bit so maybe there's
something you can do about this but it's
very hard to say so knight's the d4 by
rapport uh we have knight characters on
d4 and now you really want to capture
with the c pawn but the rook and c1
would be hanging and if you capture with
the e pawn then you run into some like
knights to e4 and black well black has a
very very enjoyable game if f3 there's
even knight captures in c3 so you have
to worry about that as well and now if
rook captures just queen a5 and that's
the problem of leaving your king in the
center of the board for for too long if
king d2 now we play bishop f5 harass the
queen here and after queen to e3 rook
f38 and white is completely busted
uh so after knight to d4 uh we have
queen captures on d4 you kind of want to
connect your pawns but here it's just
not possible and now knight to e4
knights to e4 asking again what do you
want to do here again ideas like knight
captures and c3 followed by queen to a5
become possible so f3 and now what do
you play here is it is it possible to to
do it again well here not really because
if you capture on c3 now rook captures
on c3 and queen to a5 now we play bishop
to e5 that's the difference and there's
no good way uh to do this for example if
f6 yes we are now threatening the bishop
here but now we can just move the queen
queen to d3 and after f captures on e5
then queen to g6 check and the white has
at least a perpetual here so uh
well it's possible to go for something
like this it's uh not much but because
you're gonna capture here with check uh
and then you're gonna pick up the bishop
with check and the white white will
definitely play for for advantage here
and if you play knight captures on g3
instead of trying this uh well crazy
maneuver then h captures then you allow
white to get a nice semi-open file for
his rook so instead after this um uh
sorry after this f3 move attacking the
knight we have knight back to d6 and now
bishop captures on d6 we have queen
characters on d6 and now
after all has been traded off the board
and now rapper plays h4 and now he wants
to open up the
uh
the the king side and try to use this
rook to get some checkmating ideas in in
there so here we have queen to b6
there's no way we're allowing any of
that to happen so we're just offering a
queen trade and there's really no good
square for the queen
other than going back with some like
queen to d2 because you also have to
keep an eye on the e3 pawn so h captures
on g5 we're going into an end game queen
captures and now e captures on d5 c
captures is still impossible because the
rook would hang so here he captures on
d5 with h captures on g5 and now rook to
h5 going after the g5 pawn so f6 there's
really nothing better
and now bishop to d3 so again trying to
get control of this h7 square
rook to f7 and now king to d2 now the c3
pawn is protected and you can start
activating your c1 rook
king to f8 and now rook to e1 attacking
the bishop here and now you have to
decide how to defend here bishop to d7
is one idea and might be uh a
better one than the one that tari chose
he decided to defend the bishop with
rook to c6 but now we have rook to h8
with check king to g7 of course you
don't want to go to e7 uh well there's a
reason for that and we're gonna discuss
it but not right now uh and now rook eat
the h1 now threatening rook eight to h7
checkmate because the bishop is covering
the g7 square so only one move for tari
he has to play f5 now block this light
square bishop's diagonal and now rook 1
to h7 check king to f6 and now rook to
h6 with check and now the idea is the
same you can't go to e7 that's the
problem because here
white has a well just a beautiful
beautiful
winning idea so even pause the video and
try to find this beautiful idea in this
hypothetical hypothetical situation
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being an excellent
solver of hypothetical uh situations and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's bishop to b5 that's right
we win the rook the rook can't move uh
and that's it we're just gonna win it uh
win the exchange and that's it because
if the rook moves then it's the very
nice rook to e8 to check and there is no
defending this bishop here because the
d7 square is not available to the black
king you have to play king to d6 now
we're going to play rook captures on e6
with check we're already up a piece
we're gonna further trade down and it's
an easy win for us so instead after rook
to h6 king to g7 has to be played and
now comes uh well again bishop to b7 uh
bishop to b5 going after the rook uh you
could try the
uh simpler approach which wins you upon
and that's just delivering check for
example rook eight to h7 checking to g8
and now we trade here captures for
example king captures because if the
bishop captures that's just no fun we're
going to trade the rook here and our
position is better so king captures and
now we're going to deliver this czech
king f6 and now rook captures on v7 so
this would win you material uh but
arafort is not the kind of guy that goes
for material he wants to keep the
tension bishop to b5 attacking the rook
now rook the c8 offering a trade of uh
pair of rooks we have rook eight the h7
check of course not allowing the the
trade king to g8 and now trading on f7
rook captures on f7 and now bishop
captures an f7 we have bishop to d7 this
was the idea now we win the pawn there's
no way for black to stop this rook to d8
and now bishop captures an f5 so now we
won a pawn and we have to somehow
capitalize on that so king g7 rook to h7
check we have king to f6 and now uh one
might even consider g4 here but rapper
just goes back bishop to d3 uh so you
know there's a there's a principle in
chess that says that pawns cannot go
backwards so maybe if you're not sure or
you don't gain anything by it uh you
know immediately uh maybe wait with that
pawn push so bishop to d3 and now rook
to c8 it's hard for black to make any
use of this rook because the white rook
is covering the h file there is no way
to gain anything along the e file
because all of these squares are
controlled by the king and by the light
square bishop and this pawn is nicely
protected but it's also on a dark square
so the light square bishop can't really
help out with that and this pawn being
on a light square only prevents black
from freely roaming with the bishop so
rook h6 check king e7 now comes bishop
to f5 putting pressure on the rook here
rook to c4 and now king to c2
we have b6 by black and now king to b3
we have rooked back to c7 and now bishop
to g4 so now you might have some plans
of rook h7 bishop here trying to trade
down because if you go into a king and
pawn in game you're up a pawn here it's
going to be very easy
so of course that would be completely
winning so king back to f8
and rook to f6 now again trying to get
bishop to e6 or h5 to just trade
everything and then win a king and pawn
end game king to g7 tardy of course
cannot allow this and the rook to d6 now
now uh this pawn will uh you know come
under fire uh we have rook to e7 uh and
now trying to get uh some action here
along the back rank but uh uh rapport
says uh just g3 you're welcome to ring a
rook to e2 it doesn't really have any
targets there so king back to f8 and now
a3 uh we have rooked the e1 and the now
comes rook to d8 with check uh rook the
e8 blocking this uh and now just rook
captures on e8 uh
robert says all right the the
same colored bishop end game will be
very very um uh you know enjoyable for
me king capture sun e8 and now king to
b4 now we want to get our king here pick
up the a7 pawn pick up the b6 spawn and
win the game so of course the black king
has to prevent this king to d8 we have
king b5 king to c7 king to a6 and king
to b8 the pawn is now nicely defended
but now
i'm sure you guys already know what's
happening here for the second time feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding the
only move that wins the game and on
being such a spectacular end game player
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course f4 we
create a pass pawn and that's it there's
no way for for black to keep an eye on
the pawn uh because our light square
bishop will always be able to control
one of the squares that's needed to
advance the pawn further so here g
captures on f4 g captures now bishop to
g6
but the just f5 we have bishop back to
e8 now yes we have control of this
square
but it doesn't help all that much we
have bishop to f3 going after the pawn
here bishop to f7 now comes a4 uh we
have bishop to g8 trying to keep an eye
on everything now bishop to h5 taking
away this square ended this square from
the bishop so what do you do here now f6
f7 and there's really nothing you can do
here king to c7 was played you have to
make a move but that means giving up
this pawn and after king captures on a7
it was in this position and move 58 that
arientari resigned the game and another
brilliant victory for rihard rapport in
classical time format uh which just you
know
accelerates his advancement uh to the to
the world's top five and it seems like
rapport is the only one playing
classical
just as he's pretty much the only one
winning the games in classical and this
uh is doing wonders for him uh so here
you resign uh i mean there's nothing to
do you're down two pawns but the
simplest way would be let's say king to
c6 we're going to play f6 there's no
stopping f7 king c7 you're gonna play f7
you have to give up the bishop here and
that's it you have to play something
king to c6 but now we can even give up
our bishop i mean we are up too much
material of course three pawns will be
completely winning so of course tari
knows this and after king captures on a7
he resigned the game and what does this
mean for our standings uh well uh
rapport is now again well not again but
still leading the tournament as you can
see he's on twelve and a half points
followed by annie ponchi with nine and a
half then magnus carlson with nine uh
sergey karjakin uh within and a half
alireza furujo with six and arientari
with three points so yeah going into the
second half of the tournament rapport uh
extends his lead and uh he is now very
very close to catching up to wesley so
anish geary and alexander grieschuk in
the in the world top rating uh he is you
know
only missing a few points to grab the
the world number six spot in in in the
classical rating and then we'll see if
it's possible for him to overtake levon
arunan uh and then maybe maybe even
further all right so this could be in
the
the best tournament he's had in a very
long time uh and it just propelled him
you know straight into the
top of the world chess he was always in
the top of the world chess but now you
know getting into that top five that's
just
uh that's just everything
uh so once again that's the game a
second game we have a very interesting
end game you know uh with some light
square bishops and some pawns so hope
you guys enjoyed that uh i would like to
thank happy birthday heather rose uh tom
keaching stephen sharnley your
usedokay.com and customches.com for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day